okay lot of news from over the weekend
first let's just get this out of the way
so we can deal with the data and then
move on to some other stories Donald
Trump is made pretty significant headway
in the polls over the last week I we
don't spend a lot of time on this we
like to check in with the polls once or
so a week let's start as we often do
first just with our actual polling data
which i will show you here from Real
Clear Politics you will see that in the
polls in which Hillary Clinton is
leading in many she is now leading only
by 12 or a tie Donald Trump is leading
in that one recent CNN Oh RC poll and if
you look at the trend lines on the graph
the red line representing Donald Trump
climbing and the blue line representing
Hillary Clinton declining let's now
check out the 538 election forecast
which predicts the chance that each
candidate has of ultimately winning in
November nate silver's 538 has it at
roughly seventy percent chance for
Hillary Clinton thirty percent chance
for Donald Trump and a lot of this
really hinges on some of those swing
states which in all of these maps you
see Ohio and Florida sort of flipping
back and forth between leaning one way
or the other the New York Times has a
feature called the upshot they also have
a similar sort of assessment of the
chance of winning and on that one you
will see that Hillary Clinton currently
at eighty percent Trump twenty so better
numbers for Hillary Clinton in the New
York Times upshot then on Nate Silver's
538 but still what you do see is that
those numbers have decreased for Hillary
Clinton and increased for Donald Trump a
sort of since the start of September in
the last few days of October what about
the electoral vote map prediction based
on State polling so instead of looking
at national polling we say okay
Massachusetts State polling as Hillary
ahead so we will fill in the map blue
and sort of repeat that for 50 states
and see who comes out ahead this graphic
is from
no I skipped one I this is the right one
yes so this is a graphic which explores
the most likely electoral vote totals
for Hillary Clinton of course you need
to 72 win any scenario which has Hillary
Clinton above 270 means Hillary Clinton
wins any scenario which has Hillary
Clinton below 270 means Donald Trump
wins now as you can see the scenarios
are heavily heavily clustered around 340
or so electoral votes for Hillary
Clinton that is very very aggressive
there is no doubt that that would be a
major major win for Hillary Clinton but
we will see if the electoral vote
predictions change and then lastly now
we will go to the electoral dash vote
dot-com map uh and show you that
currently electoral dash vote dot-com
which is a great website that's been
around for at least three or four
election cycles currently has only
Florida tied every other state they have
for either Hillary Clinton or Donald
Trump their prediction based on
state-by-state polling as of today
September 12th is Hillary Clinton 306
Donald Trump 203 certainly less
favorable for Hillary Clinton uh than
what the New York Times has and I also
want to show you a path to victory chart
this is super super interesting the New
York Times and you can check out all of
the stuff on newyorktimes.com the New
York Times is set up sort of like a
hierarchy tree which examines different
scenarios starting with if Hillary
Clinton wins Florida you can look at a
number of scenarios there and if Donald
Trump wins Florida and then you can say
okay if Hillary Clinton wins Florida but
loses Pennsylvania what scenarios are
there the summary of this graph is that
Hillary Clinton has 903 paths to victory
whereas Donald Trump has only 111 path
to victory based on what is going on in
swing states right doesn't make sense to
do
scenario where Hilary loses
Massachusetts because Hillary's not
going to lose massachusetts uh so that
is that and i think i may have ended up
going out of order with some of these
but i think at this point we have
covered every graphic that i wanted to
cover so what's the message here the
message is those who are saying it's
over and Hillary has it one well I don't
think so those who are saying Trump is
surging and is right in this thing and
has as good of a chance as Hillary
Clinton to win well I don't think so the
consensus is over the last week to ten
days Donald Trump has absolutely closed
in on Hillary Clinton's lead but he's
got a long way to go and when we look at
historical data the predominant leader
in post convention August and into
September typically typically does win
in November anecdotally there were poles
in two thousand uh eight at this time
that had John McCain ahead he ultimately
lost so is that failsafe is it foolproof
no it's not but these are the facts and
we will see what happens and of course
the Hillary Clinton health situation
which i am not going to ignore as many
of my favorite trolls on Twitter have
suggested I would be doing over the
weekend that could be a factor we will
be talking about that we will be talking
about a lot of different issues today